восьма ранку у селі анисів на
Чернігівщині для когось тут це лише
початок дня для пані любові розпал
роботи у рідному дворі
[музика]
ось кролики це мама їхня
лопає як ну а курочку чи пульки ціпи
ціпи ціпи ціпи 75-річна любов прочухан
показує нам дрова які вже наколола на
зиму А на городі чекає картопля її
одразу передасть через волонтерів
багатодітним родинам і військовим а
тепер я хочу трошки їм помогти
Як то кажуть і всім і мене все мій
великий
словом человек
если в його велика сила волі які у
проробив всю жизнь не пролинився він без
родини може бути не може секрет її праці
зараз жартує пані любов у протезі що
міцно тримає її замість ампутованої ноги
оце такий
Ну я вже ходить їм Я вже де його
привикла
заховала от лишніх глаз
болить і сиджу болить де кажу Хай болить
а я буду робити
кожну годину перерва на процедури Оце я
Павла на городі тут уже в мене все мокре
я скидаю у коліно я щоб не натерли там
трохи є як я
виточки поклала на коліна бинтам
обмотала про те що таке протез любов
прочухан геть не знала що рік тому
навесні 2022-го тоді у березні село
анисів опинилося на лінії оборони від
російської армії під час
повномасштабного вторгнення РФ обстріли
тривали щоденно У нас тут хлопці
волонтьори яке так вийшла на улицу Ага
хлопці стоять а воно ж чуть не стріляють
значить надо робити рубають дрова зір
хлопця нема ховаються я ховаюся попри
небезпеку у рідному селі пані любов
вирішила щодня доїти корів і готувати
домашній сир для односельців ЗСУ і
волонтерів
вагу наробила цього ж із молока наварила
наварила кавунаташа вона дану Наташа
кажу бери бери в тебе кажу там багато
дітей що А корови нема на і мала Кай і
син і творогу і сиру наплавила Нати вам
дівки бути корисною саме Так жінка
обрала невипадково розглядаючи старі
фото пані любов розкриває ще один свій
секрет в минулому вона членкиня
української команди професійних доярок
що були призерками СРСР з машинного
доїння корів ну було ж таке було
посилали на соревновані по району перше
місце по області да павук по Україні
третє місце по советскому Союзу тоді
було 10-11 місто саме за улюбленою
роботою якою жінка займалася і на пенсії
вона ледь не загинула торік під час
авіаудару росіян на сільській фермі я
той який виїхала з сарая у на велосипеді
і потом ну проїхала Я ж Вам кажу Ну так
як до хатинці і я впала з велосипеда
Якби я йшла пішки
ми не було вище коліна А так як я їхала
на велосипеді і моя нога була на верхній
педалік мені считайте у косточку ударило
уже з розірваною ногою на це подвір'я
поранено жінку принесли на руках
односельці
Добрий день
красуня наша а сьогодні сюди заходить
довгоочікуваний гість пані любові
волонтер який торік з під обстрілів
евакуював її до лікарні у столиці коли я
попала у больницу так
конечно
а він вечір
заходить на такий красавчик
і каже я Славка
я вас заберу Київ
[музика]
подивитися і забираємо привезли вони
мене туди ж у апеляційному і каже
дивіться надам кутіровать вам я так
дивлюся чи перепугу таке наче не
пужалась така і наче бачу що сухожилля
наче білі ниточки тіліпаються
на другий день сиділа на ліжку я прийшов
провідувати і завідуючий відділення каже
я здивований
бабуся ну і так гарно перенесла і
наркоси ампутацію І саме головне що вона
позитивне
це кадри вже з Австрійської клініки де
відбувався другий етап реабілітації пані
любові протезування на виписці жінка
танцювала із протезом на честь лікарів і
волонтерів небайдужі не припиняють їй
допомагати і сьогодні зокрема волонтери
готуються завершити відновлення
обстріляної хати пенсіонерки утеплення
стін фасаду і утеплення покрівлі два
фасади вже
утеплили своєю місією на знак вдячності
любов прочухан вважає власний вклад у
волонтерство зібрану з городу картоплю
м'ясо та консервацію регулярно готує і
передає своїм рятівникам аби ті віддали
нужденним і ЗСУ це шок
бо це для вас іще огурці
у селі анисів кажуть місцеві любов
прочухан зажила неабиякої слави як
волонтерка і мотиваторка для інших і
танцює вам скажу співає із протезом
кожний папітайте всі її знають
директорка сільської школи запевняє
популярність активної пенсіонерки серед
благодійників притягує увагу волонтерів
і до проблем самого анисова де нещодавно
профінансували відновлення навчального
закладу і будівництво укриття для дітей
своєю харизмою Вона показала Як можна
виходити і самих складних ситуацій і так
як вона за віком за нас старша то це є
знаєте такий гарний приклад всім нам не
приховує свого бажання далі допомагати
іншим та надихати їх і сама пані любов
вийде в город і я радію сама собі що я
і то в мене є і то в мене є є і з руками
і ногами
А мене все як хто в таку ситуацію попав
не здаватися
сили волі о
і
не падай духом
А я можу А я не здамся А я буду І все
невдовзі на пенсіонерку чекає повторне
протезування і подальша реабілітація
каже волонтер В'ячеслав втім до лікарні
жінка не поспішає Доки має хатні справи
Славка переробимо тоді коли я покопаю
картошку усе зроблю
отменять